in that moment I understood of course
I'm not worthy I'm playing with the
house is money I've been playing with
the house this money since this game
began from the moment I was born I was
standing on a mountain of gifts
do you think we actually think we're
funny like it isn't more a reaction from
other people because sometimes you
talked about naivete with Phoebe and you
know sometimes when you see someone
that's like that in real life they don't
realize that they're so funny that's
what's funny about it that's true AI
doesn't know how funny it is doesn't
doesn't realize well that's backward
actually it's not funny but sure people
are like that and people will say oh
you're so funny now let's just let's
just imagine that you said those words
to me when I was 25 years old oh you're
so funny
I would have had a couple of problems
with it one is I'd have trouble fitting
it into my Paradigm because I don't
think of myself as funny I mean I do
think of myself as funny but not just
funny so I might feel like I'm I'm
achieving a low Target but that's not my
big problem my big problem is I have to
fit your approval into my mindset you
just told me I'm funny and now you're
demanding that I feel how I feel about
what you just told me
because I'm creative and I'm insecure
and I'm 25.
I have a lot of trouble owning your
validation I have a lot of trouble
feeling good about the approval you just
gave me
I carry in my mind a construct that says
I'm not worthy
and because I'm not worthy I have
trouble accepting praise and also
because I'm not worthy I have trouble
operating effectively in Creative spaces
for myself as a practitioner I had a
very clear moment of Revelation
where I learned the difference between
fearing I'm not worthy and knowing I'm
not worthy and in that moment my life
changed I'll tell you about it short
story
I was
struggling with my Hollywood career but
I was teaching effectively and because I
was teaching effectively I got invited
to go to Australia with some very Heavy
Hitters from Hollywood who would provide
the glamor and then I would provide the
content
and at the first break
three young women came up to me young
adult women and I remember them clearly
because they had great Australian
empowering names for girls their names
were respectively Saturday Sheridan and
rebel oh wow you guys are doing your
kids some favors here giving them
staunch names like that but this is what
they said to me I I remember clear as
day I was standing on the left side of
the auditorium on the steps and after
the presentation they said these words
they said of all the presenters here
today we like you best
and I heard myself say the words I'm not
worthy and I understood that to mean
what they're telling me is they
appreciate my gifts
and what I'm realizing In This Moment is
those are gifts they were given to me
all this time I've been walking around
the world saying what did they find out
I'm a fraud what if they find out I'm
not worthy this is fearing I'm not
worthy
in that moment I understood of course
I'm not worthy I'm playing with the
house is money I've been playing with
the houses money since this game began
from the moment I was born I was
standing on a mountain of gifts
The Gift of Life the gift of this brain
which is a good brand okay the body yeah
you know can't shoot a basketball can't
hit a hockey puck but I can tell a joke
and I can think things through that's a
gift that's I developed it I worked with
it I made it more but in that moment I I
understood I spent all my time wearing a
I'm not worthy they're gonna find out
I'm a fraud and I'm never going to feel
good about myself the minute I accept
that I'm not worthy that I'm standing on
a platform of endowed gifts
I got nothing to lose I'm already
winning I'm winning in a way that
transcends what you might say to me
that's positive or negative and that's
really when my
my best life began
and I'm sorry you were how old at this
point I will have been just shy of 40.
ah not that young interestingly how did
I get it was 93 or 94 and I was born in
55 so yeah just just shy of 40. how did
I get that deep into the game before
catching on
I think I spent a lot of time
distracting myself with outcomes that
allowed me to advance but didn't allow
me to explore I spent five years as a
singer-songwriter singing and playing
guitar like Bob Dylan until I realized
there were two things I couldn't do
particularly well sing and play guitar
I came to Hollywood and spent five years
doing situation comedy with some degree
of success but
not connecting with the
the environment the ecosystem that I
wanted to be in not at home in that
environment and not not willing to admit
it once I discovered that I could teach
meaningfully and inspirationally
then I
a lot of doors started to open because I
was no longer rejecting that part of me
that was my best part
I had some problems with it as you might
expect because there's this old cliche
those who can't do teach
and I was afraid at the age of 35 30 35
I was afraid if I turn my back on
writing and just become a teacher then
I'm going to be one of those those who
can't do teach guys and though I'd
already been teaching for 15 years in
one form or another teaching adults I
taught songwriting when I was learning
songwriting so I figured who better
qualified to teach it than someone
learning how to do it same thing when it
came to Hollywood I taught a class on
breaking into Hollywood because I'm
doing it let's give it a try if I was a
teacher all along but I didn't accept
myself as a teacher I thought it was
only valid as a practitioner
and then I had a student liberate me
from that in in about the same time
students said well how about those who
can do do both and I said that's my path
because I know me I'm not happy when I'm
not writing but I'm also not happy when
I'm not teaching so if I can spend half
my time writing that'll help my teaching
and if I can spend half my time teaching
that'll definitely help my writing and I
can move back and forth between these
two worlds that's my place if I can
accept that that's my place by letting
go of earlier expectations then I can
start to operate effectively I was
afraid that I would stop writing so I
made sure I didn't stop writing and two
dozen books and countless teleplays and
screenplays later I can say without fear
of contradiction I never stopped writing
I paused from time to time
but the fire never went out and I never
really needed to worry that it went
would go out I just hadn't found the
most effective version of myself the
most effective version of myself is
certainly he who can do teaches he who
can teach does
how fascinating so it was a student that
posed that that's wonderful and this is
why we teach because when we teach we
learn I mean over and over again I so
much of what I've shared with you today
comes out of experiences that I've had
in other classrooms elsewhere and I've
cited them as such I told you about the
time that I modeled failure by accident
and got such a big reward part of what
makes me effective is stockpiling
discoveries
my my Keen attention to my own process
gives me better Effectiveness in
subsequent situations as as that example
uh if you accept people's praise then
you only have to feel good you don't
have to feel bad
if you can't accept their praise because
you don't think you're worthy of your
prey their praise you're just going to
spend some time feeling bad and who
needs that okay I learned that in that
moment so later in other places where
people have wanted to
guruize me and they have they've wanted
to treat me as a guru and I can live
with that because I understand there's
two kinds of gurus there's the high Guru
who is above the people and there's the
logo who basically drinks and so I'm
kind of a low Guru I'm with the people
we're all there together I'm a
practitioner just like you so if
somebody wants to say I value you
for what you know
now I'm in a place of real healthy
Tranquility where I can say I appreciate
the value that you're giving me because
I'm not dependent on it
see the thing for me in Hollywood was
and even really up to this moment of
Revelation I only felt good about myself
when outer reality told me I was doing
well when I was validating validating
myself through the validation of others
the hard lesson that Hollywood taught me
was Hollywood will extend validation to
you and then take it away arbitrarily
suddenly and for no particular reason
other than they're no longer interested
in you so a lot of what I struggled with
in that time was I'm not getting the
validation that I need from Outer
reality and I don't know how to get it
from within once I learned how to get it
from within all of those problems
stopped
how did I get it from within just by
recognizing that I stand on a platform
of gifts and my only job is to exploit
my gifts
if I do that everything's going to fall
into place the questions of am I am I
good or bad am I achieving or not
achieving am I high am I low no that
matters my only job is to be in my
practice to make creative choices and
and Achieve creative outcomes because
that's what I'm intended to do with my
gifts now
let's dwell on that for a second because
this is somebody who understands that
his gifts include creating and teaching
but he also understands that they don't
include negotiating they don't include
combat they don't include excellence in
sports they don't include getting things
from high shelves
so it's not just a matter of saying wow
I'm so high and mighty I have all these
gifts it's rather a matter of saying
this is who I am and all of the
qualities that I have I can be in
acceptance of not because I can accept
good qualities and bad qualities alike
but because I can see past the value
judgment of good and bad I can accept
everything about myself like everything
else as I've said before it's not a good
thing it's not a bad thing it's just a
thing that is
and if I have limitations I use tools if
I can't reach a high shelf I use a stool
if I can't draw a sunset I use AI why
wouldn't I